Sweden will become a full-fledged member
of the alliance and this is good for
Sweden it is good for turkey it's a good
for a whole nato in Alliance and not
least it's good for the Baltic region
for Lithuania and the other countries in
this region
at the summit also make important
decisions sending a clear message to
Ukraine that we stand by Ukraine for as
long as it takes and expect allies also
to reach the commitment to provide a
military support to Ukraine to help them
liberate a more land
on the membership issue I also expect
that allies will
send a clear and positive message on the
path forward towards membership for
Ukraine
I have proposed a package of three
elements with a more practical support
with a multi-air program to ensure full
interoperability between Ukrainian
forces and the NATO forces this is move
this will move Ukraine closer to Nato to
strengthen the political ties with the
establishment of the NATO Ukraine
Council where we have the inaugural
meeting tomorrow with president
and then to remove the requirement for
membership action plan this will turn
the membership process for Ukraine from
a two-step process into a one step
process so all of this will send a
positive and strong message
then allies will also make important
decisions to further strengthen our
deterrence and defense with new defense
plans and the more forces on high
Readiness we also agree that I also
expect that Alice will agree a more
ambitious defense investment pledge
where two percent of GDP for defense
will be a minimum and then lastly I look
forward to also welcoming our
indo-pacific partners at this Summit
this will demonstrate that Securities
not Regional security is global and
therefore our welcome the partners from
Australia New Zealand South Korea and
Japan and with that I'm ready to take
some questions
CNBC so security guarantees it didn't
stop Vladimir Putin in 2014 The Budapest
memorandum was worth this piece of paper
to Vladimir Putin what is concrete about
the future security guarantees for
Ukraine that will make a difference and
the second point if I may on the same
issue
Ukraine has fears that perhaps security
guarantees will change over time with
different leaderships perhaps a
different presidency in the US what kind
of guarantees are there that security
guarantees will Outlast and any changes
of presidency in the United States thank
you sir well they're all agree that the
most imminent tasks now is to ensure
that Ukraine prevails as a sovereign
independent nation in Europe so the most
important thing we can do is to continue
to provide weapons ammunition Military
Support to Ukraine Because unless
Ukraine prevails us as a nation as a
democratic nation in Europe there is no
issue to be discussed about security
guarantees or or membership in NATO at
all then on the membership issue
we will send the clear message a
positive message on the path forward the
text in their communique will be made
public within hours later on today when
all allies agree on the text but I
expect that allies will agree a message
which is clear on the need to move
Ukraine closer to Nato with making sure
that the forces are interoperable with
the NATO Ukraine Council and also
removing the requirements for the
membership action plan this is all about
moving a Ukraine closer to Nato
membership which will
be extremely important for Ukraine and
also demonstrates the unity and the and
the strength of the message that NATO
allies are sending to Ukraine
uh in the region is worsening so we have
the Russian forces occupying separation
nuclear power plant we have the
announcement of Vladimir Putin to put
Russian nuclear warheads in Belarus what
will be the reaction of NATO if some
nuclear accident happens in the parisia
or these nuclear warheads will be really
placed in Belarus what will be the
response of NATO countries
so first of all the new coretric of
Russia is dangerous and Reckless and
Russia must know that a nuclear war can
never be won and must never be fought
NATO allies of course monitoring closely
what Russia is doing we condemn the
announcement that Russia will deploy
tactical nuclear weapons to Belarus we
are monitoring closely what they are
doing so far we haven't seen any changes
in the Russian nuclear deployments
posture that requires any changes from
our side but we remain Vigilant and and
we will ensure that we of course are
ready to protect and defend every NATO
allies Ally against any Potential Threat
on the situations our message to Russia
is that they had to withdraw their
forces
because the way they now behave
in in separitza is undermining the
security of this biggest nuclear power
plant in Europe
membership language in the conclusions
will the word invitation feature in the
conclusions and the second question a
few days ago Mr zelenski said there was
no point in coming to vernias if there
was no concrete discussion and concrete
thing that NATO could offer what would
that have meant to Nato and now what is
your feeling about this will he come
president zelenski welcome I'm glad to
welcoming him uh both at the dinner
tonight and at inaugural meeting of the
NATO Ukraine Council tomorrow
um natal I will send a strong United
positive message on the path forward for
Ukraine but I will not go into the exact
language now because that will be made
public when the communicate within text
is agreed and that will happen later on
today but rest assured the message will
be positive the message will be strong
the message will be United from NATO
allies this is both about the path
forward for membership but also about
the most imminent task and that is
Military Support Because unless we
ensure that Ukraine win this war unless
we ensure that Ukraine prevails as a
certain independent nation there is no
membership issue to be discussed so we
have to understand the timelines the the
tasks and the first and most imminent
task is to ensure that Ukraine prevails
and President Putin does not win this
war
foreign
thank you Mr Secretary General can you
say something about the decisive issues
in the last moments of the negotiations
between turkey and Sweden how important
were for example the f-16s probably
arriving from the United States and
lastly how relieved are you personally
of this result
well the agreement is public you read
the statement under that statement
addresses the same issues that we agreed
in Madrid so the agreement yesterday it
builds on and is implementing the
agreement that we reached last year in
Madrid so this is about stepping up the
corporation to fight terrorism which is
extremely important for turkey but also
for all NATO allies it's about the
lifting restrictions on arms exports and
it's also about ensuring that this is a
long-term continued cooperation
between Sweden and turkey also after
accession so so there are no other
agreements the agreement is public as
the agreement was in Madrid and uh and
the good news is that
we have then paved the way for Sweden to
become a full member and I would thank
President erdogan also thank
[Music]
for their constructive approach that
enabled the decision yesterday to allow
a student to become a full member and
for turkey than to to ratify the
accession uh protocols for uh for Sweden
regarding the agreement raised by turkey
and Sweden yesterday I would like to ask
will not act as a guaranteer especially
for promises my advice we decide new
promises May to be fulfilled not only
before but after the ratification as
well
I'm absolutely confident that both
Sweden and turkey will adhere to the
agreement and also that this will
continue after accession and to ensure
that we actually established last year
in Madrid what we call the permanent
mechanism to ensure the continued
cooperation on the fighting terrorism
and and and
just the fact that we have met many
times since Madrid to step up our
cooperation in the fight against
terrorism demonstrates that this is a
lasting agreement an elastic commitment
that will also be there after Sweden
joins the alliance out
a question on the bilateral or
multilateral security guarantees which
are not part of the NATO as I understand
can you elaborate a little bit what they
will contain which countries will
participate and as of what time they
will be valid so is it only when there's
a ceasefire when the war is over so and
and will it be concluded here at the
summit thank you
at the NATO Summit we will agree a
package for Ukraine with more practical
support with stronger political ties and
also decisions to move Ukraine closer to
Nato membership and the exact language
will be available later on this today
then some allies are also then
having a bilateral or multilateral
dialogue with uh with Ukraine on a
framework to have in place to ensure
continued support for Ukraine I think it
would be wrong if I go into the exact
language of that and also exactly
how that will be made public but of
course this will complement and and
supplement the decisions made at the
NATO Summit
uh Secretary General the question about
potential Wagner mercenaries and Belarus
are there any traces of their presence
seen by by NATO thank you
the answer is no so far we haven't seen
any deployment or or movement or any
evolving forces into Belarus but of
course again we follow close to what's
what's what's happening and of course
for Lithuania enabled matters
NATO is here we are ready to defend
against any Potential Threat but so far
we haven't seen any deployment of
wagonal forces tubulars
finland's and Sweden stratification
process too slow and what kind of
message will the membership send to
Russia thank you
of the distance a very clear message to
to Russia to President Putin that NATO's
door remains open and that it is for
NATO allies to decide on enlargement
Moscow President Putin doesn't have a
veto on NATO enlargement and this is
demonstrated by the fact that Finland is
now already a full fledge member and
after yesterday agreed uh to also make
Sweden a full member that turkey will
ratify the accession protocols for uh
for Sweden so this sends a clear and
strong message and also demonstrates
that President Putin's
war or aggression against Ukraine was a
big strategic mistake he totally
underestimated the ukrainians he
underestimated the unity of NATO allies
but he also underestimated the political
consequences in countries like Sweden
and Finland he went to war because he
wanted less NATO he's getting more NATO
more NATO militia presidents in eastern
part of dance and two new members
Finland already a member and then Sweden
soon to become a member so that just
highlights the big strategic mistake
that President Putin made when he
invaded invaded
Ukraine let me know that that this has
been the
fastest accession process in NATO's
modern history that's obviously the case
for Finland which is only a member but
also for Sweden
so so this has actually gone fast you
have to remember that Sweden and Finland
applied for membership in May last year
all in June all our allies invited both
Finland and soon to be called members
then as Finland was ratified a few
months later and Sweden obtained this
invitee status after the decision in
Madrid and now also their accession will
be ratified so this has been fast and
that demonstrated unity and the resolve
and
the the commitment of NATO hours to
demonstrate that NATO's door remains
open
he will ask a meeting with you you will
meet and when and why four allows
special units for Pristina in the north
of cosum Ethiopia despite serbians and
do can do anything with that because I'm
in regular contact with uh president
Alexander Woodridge and uh of course I'm
ready to meet
um we are concerned about the increased
tensions in Kosovo and we call an old
party parties to de-escalate and to
refrain from an action that can further
increase tensions in the region NATO is
present in Kosovo we have the K4 forces
there that are there to ensure security
and stability for the for forecast one
the people living in in Kosovo we we
execute our un mandate in an in partial
way and NATO has increased its presence
in uh in in Kosovo added some hundred
extra careful troops because of the
instability and the violence and the
tensions we have seen over the last
weeks
thank you so much
thank you thank you thank you
foreign
[Music]
come on
uh we are representing Norway
at what proves to be a historic NATO
Summit I would first say that a few
countries in NATO will be more
touched by the fact that Sweden is now
becoming a member
and for the first time in modern history
the entire Nordic region will be inside
NATO and that has a profound positive
implications for the way we planned our
security our defense and how we will
contribute positively to Nato NATO is a
threat to none
this is an organizational collective
security which will be enhanced by
Swedish membership
secondly it is historic because we will
now approve updated Regional plans and
updated Regional structure command
structure and we will secure the funding
of NATO operations that is a result of
hard work in the entire Alliance and
finally we will reconfirm our support to
Ukraine Norway has committed a five
years program of support to Ukraine
militarily and in the civilian and
economic Fair
and we hope to see this meeting issue a
very clear Prospect to Ukraine that
their future lies in NATO that we
enhance our cooperation and at the first
meeting of the Ukraine NATO Council will
underline that political
Dimension so this is indeed an historic
meeting and we will make every effort to
contribute as Norway has since 1949.
well I think this will be consistent
with the pledge made in 2008 uh
Ukraine has the prospect of becoming a
part of the NATO family while war is
Raging in Ukraine we have to support
every effort to end that war and that
Ukraine can defend its sovereignty as a
democratic Free Nation
and I think an invitation should be
phrased in a way that when the time is
right and allies agree NATO can Ukraine
can be allowed in
do you feel that
enhanced
opponent
think about it this way
we are all members of NATO but we don't
change destinations again we are a
threat to none
we want peace and stability in our
region the threat has come from Russia's
aggression in Ukraine that led Finland
and Sweden to make historic decisions to
join NATO it took a bit more than a year
when that was finalized but we will
still be Finland Sweden Norway Iceland
and Denmark from the Nordic perspective
we will be contributing to peace
stability and cooperation but there also
has to be solid defense and deterrence
historical meeting for my country
and you know we are in close proximity
to the neighbor Belarus we are in close
proximity to well I think things
[Music]
incredible decisions
having a future in NATO will be on the
line
well there are discussions uh among uh
in the G7 sector of having security
guarantees assurances that is outside
NATO but I I expect that to be discussed
also here at the summit thank you
foreign
[Music]
do an invitation is Ukraine getting
today
but very clear signal
not repeating the world
it will do more first of all the
holidays so all
enough in
being done president Al zaida is enough
being done to support the Eastern flank
to support Lithuania
all the Bucharest nine countries from
the bigger Powers who are quite frankly
slower to military
as well as the support is there but
sometimes of course we would
especially reacting to what is happening
Russian military forces
then in
and I hope that
these one
attention
sorry the line is waiting so probably
it will be possible I think
really happy to
yeah okay
be able to condense to continue and we
are in here for a long run support and
we'll continue uh supporting second
topic is obviously is in our Unity is
the fact that Sweden is joining us
um and again it shows that NATO is the
best guarantee for uh for countries on
the North Atlantic side of the world to
uh to have security guarantees and we're
extremely happy to have and Finland and
our Sweden part of of NATO
nothing
from our perspective NATO really is the
is the Cornerstone of of security on the
on the North Atlantic side and
definitely in the in the European
continent what we see is that a lot of
European countries are cooperating one
with another we're doing that with the
Netherlands for uh for marine activities
we're doing that with France for our
terrestrial activity so we see that the
integration is happening maybe even more
important is the um is the industrial
cooperation that is that is happening
and that I think is something we don't
talk often enough about is we are
creating a European Defense industry
that is able to scale up in situations
like this
happy that there has found a solution
for NATO to join for Sweden to join to
join NATO turkey is a is a partner and
we've been working on a lot of topics
for example migration with uh with
turkey and it's quite clear that we will
continue in in doing so
um if Turkey wants to increase the
cooperation with uh with the European
Union obviously we're open for that and
we're open for the discussion
um it looks like that there is a new
degree of openness to open that
discussion on the Turkish side that's
good let's talk and let's see what we
can work together on
well it's definitely something that will
be discussed in the European Council but
the commission obviously has to play its
role in it and and really I wouldn't try
to try to find the diversion between the
council and the commission I think we're
quite United on that
foreign
completely
all right
that
foreign
go ahead
okay we are having this historical
Summit first of all we are again
reconfirming that Russia is the biggest
threat to NATO's Alliance and for that
threat we need to adopt new defense
plans and many of you know that before
the Madrid Summit I was explaining in
human words how how the plans
really work on the plans we had that
time a work in practice so now I'm very
glad that we got strong decisions out of
Madrid so that we moved from deterrence
posture to defense poster and today
hopefully we're going to adopt the new
defense plans that mean that we are able
to defend our territory from the first
moment from the first centimeter and
this this is very very important but
what it requires from all of us is to
invest more in the events so this two
percent have heard the defense
investment pledge that we have given is
is very important but it also is
important that all the Allies are doing
this so that we can fulfill the plans
with actual capabilities and and the
troops are ready to defend the region
and this is all necessary that it would
act as a deterrence just to bring you
example in 1988 all the Allies were
making two percent of their GDP they
were investing in defense because the
threat was real and the threat is real
today as well also one of the questions
that we are still debating is the
Ukraine membership in NATO of course we
understand that it can't happen while
the war is going on we are listening
very carefully for the worries that some
of the Allies have and I think that we
are going to reach a good compromise
that means that there will be a clear
pathway for Ukraine II native membership
because NATO's membership is the only
cheapest and actually working security
guarantee there is and if the war ends
then the opportunity window opens and
Ukraine can join also NATO and and the
positive decisions
regarding Sweden we really welcome
Sweden joining NATO this means a lot for
the whole security of our region but
also making NATO much stronger thank you
of course we can't draft Ukraine into
NATO we have to have concrete steps how
Ukraine will get into NATO when the war
is over and therefore we are working on
those very practical steps the first
thing is the Ukraine NATO Council and
that is a clear way how to consult with
the Allies equally because it works like
the article 4 for the Allies works and
there are other steps as well how to
make everything happen so that when the
conditions meet we are ready to accept
Ukraine
uh of course security Assurance is
knowing that those security assurances
we're giving some time a go as well and
they didn't really function because the
war is going on so that now the G7
countries are thinking of of providing
the military assistance to Ukraine when
the war is going on and all the other
allies can also join this pledge
G7 is is the leading Force because they
have they are the biggest allies in NATO
uh my message to those countries who are
not spending two percent uh yet is that
the threat is real I I bring you this
example in 1933 uh our defense
investment was record low because there
was no political support for it and in
1939 we wanted to increase the defense
spending by 100 but it was already too
late and with the defense spending we
can't act when the crisis is here we act
have to act before because that means
procurement that means production and
all of it and when in 1988 all the
Allies were investing two percent to
defense it was because they felt that
the threat is real and now the threat is
very realized the conventional war is
going on so I really urge all the Allies
to do it faster
this work has been very intense I mean
the debates are going on all the time we
have 31 countries that are all
democracies and democracies in
democracies we debate and we have
reached already a good good compromise
and working on this as well as I was
mentioning the NATO Ukraine council is
the first step topping the map is also
one of the conditions but also practical
steps how to get to the membership I
mean interoperability of equipment
Ukraine is using the equipment that the
Allies are giving and the ammunition so
it is already taking those boxes so what
more can we do in order to really go to
that membership
in political medium we hear the worries
that different allies have regarding the
membership but these are the same
worries that were regarding us joining
and I I just recently read the book
about NATO's history and it was very
interesting how Germans at the time when
the visigrad countries were accepted
didn't really want the visigo countries
in but then one of the representatives
said that it's better that the police
fight than the Germans fight the
Russians so here we have the ukrainians
fighting and not the not the Germans or
estonians or Americans
like
just like like the military
plans are not public so that the
concrete plans regarding helping and
defending
Ukraine are also not public because it
depends on different allies what they
can give to Ukraine to to support so so
this will be up to the Allies to decide
okay thank you
two or nothing
yeah
you
know
well yesterday we took a few very
important decisive steps towards the
Swedish
accession to Nato we had very good
conversations together with president
erdogan and Secretary General John
stoltenberg and we agreed on a joint
statement
it's well known that Sweden after 200
years of non-alignment we seek common
protection but I also want all NATO
allies to know that we also provide
security that provide common security
and we are here for the long term
we are decisive in fighting terrorism
we're decisive in fighting organized
crime so I think Sweden has a lot to to
to bring to the table as well so I'm
very happy with this result from
yesterday and now we look forward to the
to the final two ratifications
well it's a well-known position from
Sweden to have close ties between Europe
and and and turkey so that's well known
and now we are promoting a closer
economic bonds modernizing the the
Customs Union providing better Visa Visa
regulations and so forth and I think
there's a there is a fertile ground for
a closer cooperation
well I think it's as I said the Swedish
position on cooperation between the EU
and and turkey that is decades long so
that's nothing new at all and we just
recently agreed within the EU on on a on
a wording that we during the fall of
this year will will restart uh uh talks
about how how to
regain a better cooperation with turkey
so nothing is doing that I would say but
it's it's good yeah
nothing
I think I will stick to Jan
stoltenberg's wording from yesterday as
soon as possible I think that gives uh
it gives the framework for for for the
process ahead of us
I've talked quite recently with the
Hungarian prime minister so I feel very
very safe in his in his statements to me
okay
guys
foreign
thank you
no
foreign
[Music]
composition
Italians
Italian
language is
foreign
the central okay great
[Music]
foreign
videos
ultimately
thank you
foreign
recommend this is a very important
Summit because we are starting new
Regional defense plans for the Eastern
flank of the alliance for Slovakia is
very important
for Slovakia is very important
predictable coordinated air defense
mechanism I'm very glad that we have
progressed when it comes to Sweden
membership in NATO and I hope expect and
I expected the concrete progress when it
comes to membership future membership of
Ukraine presidents is
[Music]
foreign
thank you
turkey
[Music]
salad
East London
operations
okay
foreign
[Music]
now
all right
thank you
foreign
military health
reflector
and
you can't use them
questions
thank you
oh that's very nice
foreign
technical space
guys
foreign
thank you
welcome to the NATO Summit and many many
thanks for your strong leadership making
this Alliance United and even stronger
um
this Summit disorderly historic
because the agreement we made yesterday
will make Sweden a full member of NATO
and that will make our alliance even
more capable of Defending all allies
at this meeting we will also send a
clear message to Ukraine that we stand
by them as long as needed and also that
we agree on United and the positive
message message on the path forward for
Ukraine and membership for Ukraine
um
another major message from this Summit
will be that we need to invest more in
our defense and we will agree a new
defense investment pledge where we
stated that two percent of GDP for
defense is a minimum and the good news
is that European allies and Canada are
stepping up this year we have new
numbers showing that they have added 8.3
in real terms for their defense budgets
this is record high and that
demonstrates that allies are delivering
on their commitments so once again Mr
President it's great to have you here at
the NATO Summit it's good to be here and
thank you continuing to deliver
fire has made no mistress is not at all
surprised I've been uh telling the fact
that I think it's really important at
this critical moment in the Ukraine in
the whole
NATO issue that you continue to lead
data you're trusted no one knows the
situation that we're facing better than
you do
and this historic moment the adding a
Finland and swing to uh to Nato is a
consequential and your leadership really
matters and and we agree on the language
that that we've proposed that you
proposed relative to
the future of Ukraine being able to join
NATO and we're looking for continued
United native
I've heard me say my American president
heard me say many times I still think
that
that President Putin thinks the way he
succeeds is to rape NATO not going to do
that especially with you this is
so thank you for the willing to do thank
you thank you thank you thank you
what is your role in getting
agree Mr President Mr President why
won't you let the signing
as well
thank you
Sonics announce
ments
so next Airlines
the right honorable Justin Trudeau prime
minister of Canada
thank you
Her Excellency Miss kayakalis prime
minister of the Republic of Estonia
Sonic salons Monsieur Alexander
his Excellency Mr christianis karinch
Prime Minister of the Republic of Latvia
his Excellency Mr Jonas scar sterder
prime minister of the kingdom of Norway
foreign
minister of the Republic of Iceland
his Excellency Mr Nikolai denkov prime
minister of the Republic of Bulgaria
his Excellency Mr Peter Pavel president
of the Czech Republic
his Excellency Mr Yakov milotovich
president of Montenegro
we both
his Excellency Mr Mark Rooter prime
minister of the kingdom of the
Netherlands
his Excellency Mr Andre judam president
of the Republic of Poland
his Excellency Dr Robert golub prime
minister of the Republic of Slovenia
thank you
his Excellency Mr Dimitar kovachevsky
president of the government of the
Republic of North Macedonia
his Excellency Mr Zoran milanovic
president of the Republic of Croatia
Her Excellency Miss Georgia Maloney
president of the Council of Ministers of
the Italian republic
the right honorable Rishi sunak prime
minister of the United Kingdom of Great
Britain and Northern Ireland
thank you
his Excellency Mr Olaf Schultz
Chancellor of the Federal Republic of
Germany
Her Excellency Miss Mehta Frederickson
prime minister of the Kingdom of Denmark
especially
his Excellency Mr kiriniakos misotakis
Prime Minister of the Hellenic Republic
children
foreign
public of Finland
his Excellency Mr Eddie Rama prime
minister of the Republic of Albania
his Excellency Mr Pedro Sanchez
president of the government of the
kingdom of Spain
Her Excellency Miss Susanna chaputova
president of the Slovak Republic
his Excellency Mr Klaus Werner Johannes
president of Romania
his Excellency Mr Antonio Costa prime
minister of the Portuguese Republic
his Excellency Mr Ulf christerson prime
minister of the kingdom of Sweden
his Excellency Mr Victor Orban prime
minister of Hungary
foreign
[Music]
erdogan president of the Republic of
Turkey
soon
foreign
as well
The Honorable Joseph R Biden Jr
president of the United States of
America
foreign
all right
thank you
we just shrunk NATO
yeah
your excellencies for the family photo
we would invite you to look in the
central camera for eight seconds
oh
thank you
foreign
vinegar
thank you
foreign
good afternoon I think we are ready to
start if you all can uh find your seats
then we will start this Summit
so once again good afternoon welcome to
Oliver to this NATO Summit many thanks
to our host Lithuania and to you
personally president noseda the guitar
notes for hosting all of us
and let me also welcome president Nino
strong who have been at many NATO
Summits before but this is the first
NATO Summit where you actually
attend as a full fledge member so
welcome to you Sally
[Applause]
and then also a warm welcome to prime
minister John following the agreement
yesterday we will soon also be welcoming
Sweden as a full-fledged member so
welcome to you
today we will make many decisions for an
even stronger Alliance we will increase
our practical and political support
Ukraine this will bring Ukraine a closer
to Nato where it belongs we'll also take
bold steps to further strengthen our
Returns on defense including new plans
and forces for the defense of the Euro
Atlantic area and we will agree a more
ambitious defense investment pledge
let me now pass the floor to our host
the president navseda for his opening
statement please guitar on the other
floor
dear Jans my dear friends allies
it's my honor and great pleasure to
welcome you all in business
welcome to Lithia
Lithia where Freedom has never been
taken for granted
their values have always been stood for
their allies are always welcome and
cherished
lithium is a country where the principle
one for all and all for one Bears a very
special meaning and is carried deep in
our hearts
today the most brutal war is being
arranged by raged by Russia against
Sovereign and independent Ukraine
the doorstep of NATO
today allies are meeting in vilnus to
testify to the importance of collective
solidarity and defense
also to take both decisions on
how to strengthen the light security and
defense
help Ukraine to win
and boost our Partnerships with
like-minded countries in other regions
Unity solidarity and the transatlantic
Bond are irreplaceable pillars of our
success
dear friends let me wish us all
productive discussions and wise
decisions thank you
thank you so much president this ends
the public part of the meeting I thank
the media for joining us at the top of
the meeting and we'll continue in just a
moment thank you so much
foreign
tourist region at a dangerous moment in
the history of European continent
we are next to Ukraine
we as a continent are going through a
tragic
part of our history when Russia has
launched the biggest aggression since
World War II which affects a lot of
countries in Europe in the world and now
it's more important than ever to be
standing together to be in solidarity
with Ukraine and to be acting as a
European family of Nations to stop this
war and to return the continent back to
a state of peace
and Moldova is fully and entirely
committed to strengthening its
International Partnerships with those
countries and organizations that are
working together to bring peace back to
Europe to make Moldova stronger and of
course NATO is a key organization that
has managed to ensure peace and
stability in Europe and is working
together with Moldova to keep our
country peaceful stable
today I will have a speech at the
ministerial in the ministerial format
with my colleagues from the NATO
countries where we will look into ways
to strengthen moldova's partnership with
NATO with concrete initiatives
initiatives that will strengthen Moldova
and security and will help Moldova to be
continuously a contributor to Regional
security thank you
foreign
thank you
they're not uh
good afternoon I'm Deputy foreign
minister of Boston Herzegovina for us
it's a great privilege as a partner
country to be invited it willingness for
the NATO Summit this is a crucial point
of the trans
Atlantic security and this is of course
reflecting on us in Boston herzegon and
in the region of Southeast Europe where
we believe that the stronger ties with
the NATO and who is going to bring more
prosperity and more
peace in the region of Southeast Europe
I would like to thank the hosts and the
NATO for inviting and bringing Boston
herzegon as the partner country to this
Summit thank you
Google is
foreign
[Music]
NATO
Alabama
you know the main goal it's a
full-fledged membership
[Music]
that's why I will not discuss with you
right now because we will wait tomorrow
and we will hear we will see but right
now I come to sign with my colleagues
Ministers of defense of the French
countries memorandum regarding the F-16
training courses coalition
yes sure sure
My Presidents know something
good luck
foreign
why not
again
that's not a good
foreign
ladies and gentlemen good afternoon and
welcome to this short signing ceremony
we will start the ceremony with
introductory remarks from the deputy
secretary General I will then invite the
ministers to sign the document which
will be followed by the family
photograph
then the DSG will return to his meetings
and I will then invite the ministers to
make remarks before we conclude the
ceremony so without further Ado I turn
the floor to the deputy secretary
General
thank you so much Zoe
dear Wendy the minister pavco Mr Bernice
and minister
dear friends dear colleagues
it is my pleasure to be here today
for this very important signing of the
Declaration of cooperation on airspace
between Estonia
Latvia and Lithuania our dear Baltic
allies
in the context of enhancing NATO's
deterrence and defense posture I
congratulate you
for the close cooperation demonstrated
in this declaration
which will provide a cross-border
airspace solution for NATO training and
exercises
Airlines have already enhanced the NATO
air and missile defense Porsche on the
Eastern flank by deploying air and
missile defense resources and executing
enhanced vigilance activities
thus demonstrating their solidarity
determination and ability to defend
Alliance territory and our populations
airspace is a finite resource which
needs to be shared amongst civil and
Military users
the solution developed here in the
Baltic region delivers a flexible and
tangible result
in the spirit of sharing airspace while
at the same time matches the needs of
the alliance to strengthen NATO air and
missile defense capabilities
we'll continue to improve this posture
over the long term in order to enable
the Readiness and responsiveness of NATO
air and missile defense forces
the availability of suitable airspace
volume
is a key enabler in support to the
regular deployment of air and missile
defense assets for training and
preparedness has been recently proven by
a major exercise done in your region
we are also very
clear in saying that the addition of
this cross-border airspace solution here
in the Baltic states is an excellent
example of close collaboration between
not only the military forces but also
with our civilian colleagues I think
it's an inspiration for the rest of our
alliance
dear ministers dear friends their allies
thank you for your commitment for your
spirit of innovation
and the spirit of intense and
traditional cooperation on behalf of
your region and behalf of our great
Alliance thank you so much and it's a
privilege for me representative stately
General to be with you on this very
auspicious moment thank you so very much
thank you
and I invite you to sign the
Declarations in front of you
and now I don't the DSG and the
ministers for a family photograph
congratulations congratulations
foreign
it's my pleasure to now invite the
minister of National Defense for the
Republic of Lithuania to take the floor
and Hannah
the Declaration of cooperation between
the Baltic series is an important step
forward in strengthening
the air defense of the Baltic states
I welcome NATO's decision on the air
defense rotational model
it is of exceptional importance for
Lithuania
the rotational model will help to ensure
a smooth transition from Air polishing
to air defense
we work with our allies
to implement the rotational model
Lithuania is ready to provide
the needed infrastructure and host
nation support
we invest in National Air Defense
capabilities Lithuania acquires
additional nasal system
also over the next 10 years Lithuania
plans to invest about
142 million euros in the infrastructure
of the Chevrolet Air Base
we're grateful to their lives
for deploying a defense assets
for the protection of the NATO Summit
which contributes to
success of this event
at the same time we see the deployment
of air defense capabilities
as a first step
in testing the principles of the air
defense rotational model thank you
[Applause]
minister of defense for the Republic of
Latvia
thank you my fellow colleagues ladies
and gentlemen Ukrainian resolve to
protect their country and people against
Russia's ideal Firepower shows us every
day that air defense is important
component to determine course of the war
and success in it we have no reason to
think that Russia's ear and missile
campaigns would be different in any
other potential conflict given the
circumstances it's particularly crucial
to step up national and Collective
efforts in boosting our air and missile
defense capacity
I echo my colleagues and welcome NATO's
decision on air and missile defense
assets rotational model which is
incremental step four whole Alliance
I am very glad that together with
Lithuania and Estonia we have reached
another milestone in our close
cooperation commitments highlighted in
this declaration is our share to
facilitate Swift and prompt implemented
implementation of rotational model as
well as to host and contribute to Nato
deterrence activities
our trilateral achievements so far serve
as a good example for our allies we have
already established opportunities for
NATO and allies to employ our airspace
we are investing heavily in defend in
development of national air defense
capabilities our intent is to increase
defense Investments and it remains
unwavering
Latvia stands ready to provide necessary
infrastructure and host nation support
for Allied air and missile defense units
thus facilitating interoperability among
our forces and exercising transition
from Air policing to air defense
we look forward to temporarily hosting
Baltic air policing Mission from
lillarde Air Base relocation of this
vital Mission demonstrates NATO
operational flexibility and provides
novel locations in the Baltic region for
Allied fighting Jets to test
interoperability and do exercise
I am confident that sky over Baltic
states is and will remain secure thank
you
[Applause]
Melissa thank you very much and finally
let me invite the minister of defense
for the Republic of Estonia thank you
thank you very much
the arena are with us
journalists well
we all know how important a defense is
we saw that we see that every day in
Ukraine and it is clear that we have to
see what we can do more in order to
protect our people our Nations
and that declaration shows that the
Baltic states are ready to do more and
intend to continue cooperation on
developing a defense
I'm very happy that a couple of weeks
ago we agreed in NATO ministerial the
the principle that there will be air
defense rotational model and this is why
we now go to the next level and then we
try to to start to implement that also
especially on the on the NATO's Eastern
flank
Estonia of course is ready to host uh
that kind of missions and then we are
ready to offer our host nation support
to that kind of missions
we have luckily in Estonia a flexible
legal framework
in place to create the necessary
airspace training areas
and these are in accordance with NATO
regulations for flight level
we have excellent cooperation with civil
aviation and we have already hosted NATO
large scale operation exercises
with Allied Air Forces like air Defender
23.
of course
we saw already many months back that
there is a urgent need to develop air
defense and this is why we started to
look for the options as as long we don't
have our own medium range air defense
and this is why I'm very very thankful
to to Spain for deployment of Nations
surface-to-air missile defense battery
to Estonia temporary
it has given us valuable experiences and
we welcome other allies to follow their
lead
uh obviously we need to invest also more
and and definitely we will also do uh
and and we will invest to our
infrastructure we will renovate Amory
Air Base uh next year and this is why
I'm very thankful also to Latvia that
they can host the air patrolling Mission
uh that that time so we all understand
uh why we are doing that I truly hope
that also our people understand that and
and also our allies understand why it is
so crucial also during the war in
Ukraine to to give the confirmation and
certainty to our people that our
airspace is protected so thank you very
much for all of you I think once again
my colleagues and we are happy to see
that one one extra initiative among
Baltic states can can realize and I
really hope that quite quickly thank you
very much
[Applause]
ministers ladies and gentlemen that
concludes our ceremony today thank you
very much for attending and I wish you
all a wonderful rest of the summit thank
you
foreign
good evening the Secretary General will
brief you on the first session of the
Vilnius Summit and then we'll have time
for a few questions Secretary General
good evening NATO heads of state and
government took important decisions at
the critical moment for our security
we welcome Finland as a full-fledged
member of the alliance and we look
forward to welcoming Sweden as a full
member of the alliance based on the
agreement I reached last night with
president erdogan and the prime minister
kriston
we also addressed Ukraine since we last
met a year ago at our Madrid Summit NATO
allies have delivered unprecedented
support to Ukraine with more ammunition
more modern equipment and more training
to the Ukrainian forces
today allies have agreed a package of
three elements to bring Ukraine closer
to Nato
first a new multi-year assistance
program for Ukraine
to enable the transition from Soviet era
to Nato standards training and doctrines
to help rebuild the Ukraine's security
and defense sector and to cover critical
needs like fuel the mining equipment and
medical supplies
second a new NATO Ukraine Council a
forum for crisis consultations and
decision making
where will meet us equals
and I look forward to having the
inaugural meeting of the council
tomorrow with president zelenski
third we reaffirmed that Ukraine will
become a member of NATO
and agreed to remove the requirement for
a membership action plan
this will change Ukraine's membership
path
from a two-step process to a one-step
process
we also made clear that we will issue an
invitation for Ukraine to join NATO when
Allah and conditions are met
this is a strong package for Ukraine and
a clear path towards its membership in
NATO
allies have also proved the most
comprehensive defense plans since the
end of the Cold War
these are designed to counter the two
main threats we Face Russia and
terrorism
under our new plans NATO aims to have
300 000 troops at high redness including
substantial air and Naval power
robust deterrence and defense requires a
robust industrial base
so leaders endorse the new defense
production action plan this will
accelerate joint procurement boost
interoperability and generate investment
and production capacity
to do all this
we need to invest more in defense
our latest estimate show that defense
expenditure by European allies and
Canada will increase by 8.3 percent
in 2023
this is the biggest increase in decades
since 2014 they will have invested an
extra
450 billion US dollars in defense
11 allies now reach or exceed the two
percent Benchmark and we expect this
number will rise substantially next year
today allies made an enduring commitment
to invest at least two percent of gross
domestic product annually in defense and
to do more urgently to meet their
commitments
Natalie this also adjusts China
is not our adversary and we should
continue to engage
but beijing's increasing certainness
affects our security
China is increasingly challenging
challenging the rules based in National
order
refusing to condemn Russia's war against
Ukraine fattening Taiwan and carrying
out substantial military buildup
China's nuclear modernization is
unprecedented in speed and scale and
being carried out with no transparency
allies agreed to continue working
together to protect against China's
coercive Behavior
and tomorrow we will meet the leaders of
Australia Japan New Zealand and South
Korea as well as the European Union
because we are stronger and safer when
we stand together
and with that I'm ready to take a few
questions
at Washington Post
hi thanks for taking my question Michael
Birnbaum from The Washington Post
um president zielinski of course issued
a tweet in the middle of your talks that
criticized the language that you've just
agreed to on Ukraine's path toward
membership I was wondering
um what your thought was when you saw
what he was saying about what NATO was
agreeing to and what your message would
be for ukrainians who are disappointed
by this language thanks a lot
what allies have agreed today is a
strong United and positive message to
Ukraine about enduring support but also
a positive message or message on the
path forward for membership and this
includes this package of a practical
support to enable full interoperability
between Ukrainian armed forces and NATO
forces the establishment of the NATO
Ukraine Council and then the decision to
remove the requirement for a membership
action plan which actually means that
instead of two steps to become a member
there will now be one step and and we
also May declare that the invitation
will be issued when conditions are met
um
then I would like to add that on top of
that of course allies are also
providing substantial Military Support
because the most urgent task now is to
ensure that Ukraine prevails Because
unless Ukraine prevails there is no
membership issue to be discussed at all
and therefore welcome the military
support that allies have provided now
for months actually starting back in
2014 and then since the full-fledging
invasion in February last year
substantially stepping up their support
and just over
the last few days allies have made
substantial new announcements France
have announced has announced that they
will deliver a long-range cruise
missiles Germany just announced a new
package with air defense and armored
vehicles and the U.S made yet another
big announcement of more military
support and many other allies have made
different types of support including the
establishment of coalition to provide
training for F-16 fighter jets so put
together this is a strong message
which sends a positive and United
message to uh to Kiev
we'll go to the Ukrainian news agency in
the third row yeah
national news agency of Ukraine here
thank you foreign question just follow
up my colleague can we expect today a
final communique on Ukraine and we can
expect it tomorrow and could you please
specify what kind of conditions Ukraine
still need to fulfill to initiate the
accession procedure and to get an
invitation thank you
that we have agreed the communica and
also agreed the package for Ukraine that
was agreed by the leaders and I referred
the main
elements now the Practical support their
political ties with the NATO Ukraine
Council full interoperability the
removal of the membership action plan
and then of course also all the
different things that allies are
providing by laterally including with
the new announcements we have heard
today and the the last few days
um I have
uh been in close contact and regular
contact and NATO allies have also been
in regular contacts with uh with
Ukrainian officials I've discussed this
also with uh with president zelensky and
I look forward to uh to meet him tonight
and then also to have the inaugural
meeting of the NATO Ukraine Council
tomorrow
where I will set out the package of the
three elements
bringing a Ukraine closer to Nato and
this is a a strong package
over there
Andrew maybe you can just ask your
question
okay
um Andrew Gray from Reuters Secretary
General to come back to president
zielinski's remarks he said it would be
absurd if the time frame is not set
neither for invitation nor for Ukraine's
membership how would you respond to that
specific point and why have allies not
set out a time frame today
what we have agreed is a very
substantive package with many different
elements that helps to move Ukraine
closer to Nato help them to move
towards NATO membership and this is
partly a very practical support on for
instance interoperability and reforms
defense sector reforms and
interoperability are among the
conditions which are important for a
membership so that's a practical way on
moving them and moving Ukraine closer to
to Nato
then we also send a strong political
message with the language on a
membership including the language which
is now in the communique on invitation
so there's never been a stronger message
from NATO at any time both when it comes
to the political message on the path
forward for membership and the concrete
support from NATO allies Military
Support but also the practical support
on how to ensure full interoperability
so so and if you look at other
membership processes they're not been a
time
lines for those processes they are
conditions based has always been
okay we'll go to the gentleman here in
the second round
from Finland Mr Secretary General the
Baltic Sea becomes NATO's Inland Sea
NATO puts 300 000 new troops on high
Readiness
what does all this mean for Frontline
countries like Finland Estonia Latvia
Lithuania and Poland and what is NATO's
message to Mr Putin and Russia how
historic is this moment thank you
it is historic that both Finland and
Sweden will become members of a NATO
finan is only already a full member and
with the agreement uh that president
adiron and the Prime Minister
christachon and I were able to make a
last a night
Sweden has also become a full member of
the alliance this is historic it's
important for the whole Alliance it's
important for Finland it's important for
for Sweden but it is also in particular
important for the the Baltic region
because when you look at the map you
realize that for instance
this the the the possibility ability to
reinforce the Baltic region is very much
improved by the fact that we now have
Finland and and soon also Sweden as as
full members and that will be reflected
in our defense plans in our exercises in
our kpt targets and everything else we
do ask in the lines so it makes the
whole Alliance stronger and it makes
especially the Baltic region a safer it
sends the message that NATO's store is
open it sends the message that it's for
NATO allies to decide
on enlargement is not from Moscow to
deny Sovereign Nation Nations the
certain right to choose their own path
and this is again something we have
demonstrated not only in words but also
in Deeds by now allowing to new members
and sending a message to Ukraine which
is stronger than any message NATO has
ever sent before on membership for
Ukraine
um
we have the gentleman over there in the
third row
over there
uh European prop the Ukraine a Secretary
General I would ask you to clarify a bit
on conditions I understand that you
cannot list all of them it's probably
not clear but maybe you see how these
conditions would be defined agreed
because I'm afraid that
it would be read that NATO Has Lifted
membership action plan but have uh in
the invented another membership action
plan with another name which is
conditions so it's like making a bit of
a fake achievement thank you
no what we say in the communique is that
Ukraine has moved beyond the requirement
for a membership action plan just
because Ukraine has come much closer to
Nato I was actually attending the NATO
uh Summit in Bucharest in 2008 as a
Norwegian prime minister and I remember
very well the discussion there and of
course the discussion now is totally
different for many reasons and not least
because Ukraine is under full-fledged
attack by by Russia but also because
Ukraine has come so much closer to this
Alliance over all these years because
especially since 2014 when NATO allies
started to train and equip Ukrainian
Armed Forces but even more so after 20
after February last year
Ukraine has demonstrated
capabilities
skills and has been more and more
integrated with with NATO this is also a
consequence of the equipment which NATO
allies are delivered covering because
for instance when we deliver modern
battle tanks or Advanced elephant
systems
consequence of that is also more
interoperability more NATO standards
doctrines and the gradual movement from
the Soviet era doctrines standards and
equipment to Nato just by the fact that
so much equipment is now delivered and
of course when we start training with
the train of Pilots for f-16s it will
even more add to this important
interoperability which has always been a
requirement for NATO membership so this
is this is this is moving Ukraine closer
to uh to to Nato and to Nato membership
and also reflecting the fact that that
NATO has come much closer
well we have we have conditions partly
in the in in the in article 10 of the
transatlantic treaty the Washington
treaty and then of course at the end of
the day it has to be allies that assess
whether conditions are fully met or not
and that's exactly what Allison had to
agree and therefore we also refer to
both the conditions but also the need
for all allies to read that's the way we
make decisions in NATO
political
political here
um thank you Secretary General just to
follow up on this important topic I have
in front of me the text from 2008 from
Bucharest which we've all been reading
and rereading over the past weeks uh
Anita welcomes ukraines and Georgia's
your Atlantic aspirations membership in
NATO we agreed today that these
countries will become members of NATO so
if if you were explaining just to um you
know the average citizen in in the
alliance and in Ukraine people who are
really Keen to understand what was
decided today how would you explain the
difference between the tax that was
agreed in Bucharest in 2008 and the
specific language that was agreed today
there are several differences one
important difference is that I think the
next sentence so at least a bit further
down we say that the next step is
membership action plan and that's
exactly what we removed today and at
every Summit 2008 we have said uh
Ukraine will become a member the next
step is membership action plan now we
remove that so that's actually turning
this process which has always been two
steps into one step that actually moves
Ukraine closer to membership and it's a
significant difference from the 2008
language which has been reiterated at
every Summit since 2008. and it has been
also a process in NATO to make that
decision because it was not uh was a
straightforward decision to to make I'm
glad that allies agreed and it was the
main element in my package I launched in
Oslo in May at the informal meeting then
it was a questions there were questions
asked whether that was to move too fast
and therefore I'm glad that since May
since you started this discussion of
removing a map requirement all allies
today have agreed to remove a map
requirement so that's a difference
number one difference num number two is
is that we actually now have a program
for how to help and support Ukraine move
closer to Nato and that is the the
interoperability the multi-air program
but also the the the strengthening our
political ties and also reference to
that the foreign ministerial will uh
also in in the text we agreed today will
will regularly assess the progress so
this together with the fact that the the
substantial delivery of of equipment and
training just by itself moves Ukraine
closer to membership is a big big
difference there is one more difference
and that is that in 2008 Ukraine was
quite far from NATO what has happened
since 2008 has has already moved them
much closer
Swedish radio
second row
and Mr Secretary General you mentioned
the Swedish membership and you said it's
historic but we still don't know when
the ratification will be in the
parliament in Ankara and in Hungary
which day what do you know about that
and can you please tell us something
about the feelings in the meeting Hall
today when you met the other heads of
state and you have the Swedish prime
minister together with you what was the
feeling today after green light
yesterday from president erdogan
um
of course it is for the Turkish
Parliament to decide exactly when they
finalize the ratification president
adirond Medicare yesterday that he will
submit the
um ratification papers for Swedish
accession as soon as possible but then
of course also as a former
parliamentarian I think we should
respect that every Parliament has their
own procedures and also when there has
been not very controversial enlargement
this has sometimes been domestic
processes but but what makes the
agreement yesterday historic is that of
course it is a clear commitment from
president Adrian that he will submit the
papers for ratification and that he will
work with the Grand National Assembly
the Turkish Parliament to ensure
ratification and
um and this is this is historic and that
was also reflected in the meeting today
I think that almost all allies welcomed
first of all they're welcomed salinins
to the president of Finland because this
was his first NATO Summit he attended
NASA as president of of Finland as a
full member of the alliance and then
allies also expressed their welcome to
uh to uh prime minister Sean expressing
that they welcomed the agreement
yesterday and all we're looking forward
to having also Sweden as a full member
uh as soon as as possible so I felt the
kind of historic sentiment in the room
that was reflected in in what allies
said and uh and of course I welcome that
message from all of them
okay we'll take the the last question
from Ard
over there
thank you very much Marcus Christ with
Ard apparently there's a big need to
better understand what are the
conditions I'll try it the other way
around President Biden said in his
interview with CNN that Ukraine was
still short of some requirements for
joining including over democratization
what are conditions Ukraine clearly does
not meet now to get the invitation thank
you
I think we have to understand that there
are these two Dimensions which we're
addressing one is the the kind of the
level uh or the the
um to what extent they have been able to
modernize the defense and security
institutions uh uh to strengthen their
governance uh including fighting uh
corruption and this has been issues that
which has been addressed at every
enlargement of NATO uh uh because we
want good governance we want modern uh
defense and security institutions and we
want uh Armed Forces which are
interoperable with NATO we are
addressing that both the modernization
of the defense and security institutions
and
interoperability with the multi-air
program we agreed
then there is no other
dimension and that is of course the fact
that there's a war going on in Ukraine
the Ukrainian forces have demonstrated
courage skill comp mountains that has
impressed the whole world but at the
same time there is a full-fledged war
and therefore I think all allies agree
that when a war is going on uh that's
not the time for uh
making Ukraine a full member of the
alliance so these are two different
things
uh uh the question of uh of governance
corruption interoperability
um which is an issue regardless of
whether it's a war or not and then the
other issue is the the ongoing war in
Ukraine and we need to address both of
them at this at the end of the day has
to be analyzed that assess as we always
do when we have enlargement uh uh
whether the conditions are met and then
make the decision on an invitation the
important whether they're communicate
today is that we have the tools to
ensure that Ukraine moves towards a
membership we have for the first time uh
invitation as part of the language and
we have for the first time removed the
requirement for membership action plan
so this is a big step never been
stronger language from NATO on on
membership and never been more specific
announcement or what you're actually
going to do to ensure that that your
becomes a member of the alliance
thank you very much colleagues I know
there are still quite a few questions
but we'll need to to leave it uh for now
because there is a dinner of the leaders
and we'll see you tomorrow thank you
thank you
foreign
okay
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
for sure
thank you
chatting
foreign
United States
back
foreign
thank you
okay
foreign
thank you
president of the European Commission
I do
thank you
everything
foreign
Excellency Mr Nikolai denkov prime
minister of the Republic of Bulgaria
okay
thank you
all right
Her Excellency miss Catherine Jacob's
daughter prime minister of Iceland
foreign
[Music]
his Excellency Mr Zoran milanovic
president of the Republic of Croatia
Foundation
his Excellency Mr Eddie Rama prime
minister of the Republic of Albania and
Mrs Linda Rama
his Excellency Mr Klaus Verner Johannes
president of Romania
thank you
his Excellency Mr Yoon
president of the Republic of Korea and
Mrs Kim kyun hee
The Honorable Anthony Albanese prime
minister of the Commonwealth of
Australia
okay
the right honorable Chris Hipkins prime
minister of New Zealand
[Music]
his Excellency Mr Jens stottenberg
Secretary General of the North Atlantic
Treaty Organization and Mrs Ingrid
schulerud
his Excellency Mr Alexander de Crowe
prime minister of the kingdom of Belgium
and Mrs anik penders
his Excellency Mr Wolf christerson prime
minister of the kingdom of Sweden and
Mrs bergita Paulina christerson Ed
Ward
foreign
minister of the Republic of Estonia
thank you
is that slnc Mr Petro Pavel president of
the Czech Republic and Mrs ever Pavlova
thank you
Harris Lindsay miss you
president of the NATO parliamentary
assembly
cups
foreign
[Music]
prime minister of the kingdom of Norway
foreign
minister of the grand duchy of
Luxembourg and Mr Gautier Destinee
their home online
his Excellency Mr volodi mirzelensky
President of Ukraine and Mrs olena
zelenska
um
thank you
the right honorable Justin Trudeau prime
minister of Canada
thank you
it's excellent see Mr Angie Duda
president of the Republic of Poland and
Mrs Avatar con Hauser Duda
thank you
his Excellency Mr
Yankovic president of Montenegro
foreign
[Music]
minister of the United Kingdom of Great
Britain and Northern Ireland
very interesting
his Excellency Mr Ola Schultz Chancellor
of the Federal Republic of Germany
his name is
prime minister of the kingdom of the
Netherlands
foreign
[Music]
his Excellency Mr Sally linister
president of the Republic of Finland
[Music]
his Excellency Mr kiriakos mitsotakis
Prime Minister of the Hellenic Republic
and Mrs Maria Eva Virgina grabowsky
thank you
thank you very much
his Excellency Mr Antonio Costa prime
minister of the Portuguese Republic
okay
foreign
thank you
his Excellency Mr Charles Michelle
president of the European Council and
Mrs Amelie der botrengian
CE
his Excellency Mr Victor Orban prime
minister of Hungary
foreign
[Music]
his Excellency Mr receptive
president of the Republic of turkey and
mrsion
number one
if you want but usually yes
his Excellency Mr Emmanuel macron
president of the French Republic and
Madame Bridget macron
foreign
everything
The Honorable Anthony blinken secretary
of state of the United States of America
foreign
Her Excellency Miss Georgia Maloney
president of the Council of Ministers of
the Italian republic
his Excellency Mr Pedro Sanchez Perez
castejo president of the government of
the kingdom of Spain and Mrs begonia
Gomez
foreign
thank you
ladies and gentlemen we invite you to
proceed which is Palace
thank you
excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
please
thank you
foreign
okay
[Music]
foreign
thank you
ladies
just we shall now take the official
photograph please pay attention to the
camera
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much
[Music]
order
ing convention you shall now be
accomplished
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
I think
yeah
foreign
it's my great pleasure to welcome you
all
at this special dinner
today it feels as a half of the world
has gathered here in the news to discuss
security and defense
and also to get a sense of Lithuania
hospitality
the whole day we we are talking about
boosting our defenses our response to a
Russian spread and the need to help
Ukraine
tomorrow we also will also be devoted to
the most present issues
to our alliance
but this evening I would like to talk
about the vegan traditions and our
shared values
as you know businesses celebrating 700
years since it was first mentioned in
the famous letters of the enemies the
Grandview of lithium
is not only significantly strengthened
the lithium state but also pursued the
idea of opening up to the world
he sent letters to the whole of Europe
invited
your Craftsmen and others to come to
Louisiana a safe place for peaceful
dialogue
that is history
and also knows is the teachers about the
dreaming in the minister while hunting
in this same value
in his stream the Grandview saw an iron
wolf
as a strong and loud as a hundred wolves
you see even at that time the payments
we are already looking ahead and
dreaming of our wolves
a priest explained together in us that
the Iron Wolf represents a test
and the city that will be founded here
and the city will be a great capital
and its Glory will be resonate
throughout the world
today indeed I feel that the name of
Business School
I feel especially around that that NATO
Summit is taking place in the old city
of edeminos and on the uh under that
management within an emblem of Venus and
mounted armored night chasing enemies
since the terms immemorial fetus
represents Gregory or resistance and
Readiness to defend what Philippines
hold dear our land our loved ones and
friends and our feet
I believe that the same values also
constitute the essence of NATO
lithium in the sense was designated to
join the alliance of light kindness
strong wealth and freedom loving
countries
never before have some country had so
many close allies in France
never before we bear a part of something
as big as powerful and as significant as
nature
for us the alliance has already become
an essential part of our Island
let me save you each and every word for
coming here and sharing this wonderful
testimonial moments I hope that you will
enjoy your meals and Musical musical
programming and that we will have a
chance to engage in the productive
informal however discussions and now let
me raise the dose for the unity of their
Alliance all for one and one for all
things
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
is
[Applause]
I have always been asked and often been
asked why why is Angel so successful
because
most successful Alliance in history
and I think there are at least three
reasons one is our Unity
we are extremely different
you are a big family from both sides of
Antarctic different culture different
political parties in government and not
always easy to unite but the reality is
that despite all these differences we
are
[Music]
so that's the first reason why you are
successful on the unity despite all our
differences and the big e-commerce
Alliance the more different but the more
important
today is also the second is number of
success is that we are able to change
when the world is changing for four
years in the wrong thing and that was
the third Islamic Union
of organs
after 9 11 we have been at the Forefront
in the fight against Arizona and of the
day he got annexation coming up we
started again to move back to Europe to
collect the defense or have a toss and
at the summit today we have made new
important decisions to address that
report loss of collective events but the
successful item is that we change the
world is changing the third reason of
success is you have friends of Partners
no modern big Power no the older
Alliance have anything like NATO has in
our post partners and you are here to
take some of our most closest Partners
in Ukraine the European Union
and also in the Pacific Partners
Australia New Zealand Japan and South
Korea values
[Music]
Freedom democracy rural law and that is
what brings us together and that's the
reason why we are so successful so
Michael is reflection to the partners
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
excellent series yes ladies and
Gentlemen We Wish You a few more
pleasantly thank you
because